hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys were asking for a new Captain
America Civil War video and Super Bowl
Sunday is next week we're probably gonna
get some new footage so I thought I use
this video to talk about Scarlet Witch
and vision two characters that we
haven't really seen a lot from in the
trailers well there's been a little
Scarlet Witch but mostly she's just
running in standing still
obviously her story lines gonna be
bigger than just being a background
decoration and we haven't seen vision at
all mostly because he's expensive to put
on film because they have to do a lot of
special effects this is actually what
Paul Bettany looks like with the makeup
on he's really close but obviously they
animated a lot of his suit but if you
haven't read the comics Scarlet Witch
and vision have a long history together
so I'm hoping it seems like they're
going to explore that a little bit in
Captain America Civil War even though
the a storyline is gonna be Captain
America versus Iron Man it's just that
because of Avengers infinity war vision
has to get into space somehow the mind
gem has to fall into fantasies hands we
really don't know how that's gonna
happen but there have been some rumors
just to explain what they are now this
is still it like rumor level the twist
people are thinking or at least talking
about now is that vision will just
absolutely quit the earth he'll be so
upset because of what happens during
civil war and it's going to be scarlet
witch's debt that's going to push in
there but even if you have read the
comics and you know about their long
history together you're still kind of
doing the mental math in your head and
you're like well they just met each
other after Avengers age of Ultron how
much time would have had to a pass
before some sort of ship developed
between them for them to have some sort
of relationship is that even gonna be
addressed in the movie there are a lot
of Hoops that you have to jump through
before vision would get so upset at the
death of Scarlet Witch that he would
leave the earth so a quick recap of
their history in the comics I've done
some longer videos about this so I'll
put links in the description but
essentially it all boils down to visions
desire to be more human he essentially
biologically he is a human
he was just constructed as a synthezoid
you could think of him as a cybernetic
creature but I think age of Ultron did a
good job of explaining how he has human
cells bonded to vibranium it's not that
he's made a metal I know vibranium is
usually associated with metal weapons
but vibranium is the most malleable
element on the earth that's why Ultron
made the Frisbee joke because he's like
stupid humans they could have used
vibranium to do so many more complex
things but all they could think to do
was make up Frisbee somewhere Captain
America and Howard Stark are crying
corner but we like frisbees with the
mine gem and Ultron's AI consciousness
thrown in there along with Jarvis he has
what is called a synthetic soul because
he was born yesterday as he says and
he's so powerful though like his
consciousness exists on another level
from humanity so he sees things in a
different way but he yearns to be human
it's like data from Star Trek if he were
even more man than machine they even got
their own miniseries together which is
kind of like Marvel's version of a
trashy romance novel but then way way
later when comics started to get really
messed up in postmodern like oh we got
to tear these heroes down they spin out
the Avengers disassembled storyline
where Scarlet Witch takes control of
visions body she really took control of
all the Avengers they start going crazy
on each other
she-hulk rips vision apart later he's
reassembled and after EM day he does he
absolutely cannot forgive Scarlet Witch
they had two children together which is
messed up as it is later Marvel decides
to retcon that idea are twisted in a
really nasty way where it turns out that
they're just manifestations of Mephisto
so they're like two soul shards the
babies later reintegrate with him
it drives Scarlet Witch insane that's
what leads to Avengers disassembled and
day no more mutants so in the early to
mid-2000s things go downhill between
Scarlet Witch and vision pretty fast so
really I'm only expecting brief shades
of that in the movie like they might
have a relationship they'll have a
falling out over the sokovia accords and
the battle between Captain America and
Iron Man it seems like visions going to
be team Iron Man Scarlet Witch from
these pictures seems like she's going to
be team cap but because they're the two
most powerful Avengers it makes sense
that you would want them on opposite
team she should be more fun so hopefully
next week they'll release new footage
because of the Super Bowl there's
supposed to be a Captain America
Superbowl ad but because it's so
expensive to buy advertising time during
the Superbowl
usually movie studios if they drop a
trailer will drop a really short version
on TV and then they'll put a longer
version on the internet so whatever ends
up happening Marvel is gonna do
something I mean I'll totally do a video
for it so be sure to subscribe to get
that I might even do a special giveaway
we kind of already saw what vision is
capable of and Avengers age of Ultron
I think the mine gem is capable of a lot
more but of the two the Russo brothers
have been talking a lot more about
Scarlet Witch in Captain America Civil
War because she'll have a lot better
handle on her powers and obviously
they're not doing chaos magic because
Doctor Strange is gonna be the move
introduces magic but she will be much
more powerful so wouldn't it be awesome
if they did a Marvel version of no more
mutants but vision has to shut her down
before she can do that like they can't
do an M Day storyline because that's an
x-men storyline Fox owns x-men but they
could do something that looks like it
Scarlet Witch looks like she's almost
about to go nuclear so vision naturally
is like okay we have to stop this so he
goes crazy she ends up dying he's so
remorseful that he quits the Avengers
goes into space leaves him vulnerable to
Thanos you can think of a whole bunch of
reasons why vision would want to quit
the Avengers just all this destruction
Captain America Civil War someone dying
but if he is the cause of that death
that just seems like a much more
compelling reason for him to be like I
can't deal with this I'm peace I'm out
guys I got to go think about this for a
couple thousand years in space but there
was a storyline where the government
tried to disassemble vision because they
were so afraid of him I don't think that
would be a reason for him to go into
space I think being the cause of the
death of one of his close friends or
maybe even someone he's in a
relationship with would be a much better
reason
but you guys let me know what do you
think is going to be the reason that
vision goes into space and Thanos gets
its hands on the mind gem he has to get
it at some point whether it happens in
infinity war whether it happens at the
end of civil war but we're so close to
infinity war that we have to see some
fan of stuff happening in the background
I know we still need to talk about the
soldier but that's another really big
thing I'm hoping that it ends up being
the eye of agamotto and Doctor Strange
but it could also show up during Thor
Ragnarok we can talk more about Doctor
Strange whenever they drop the first
teaser which I think is gonna come with
Captain America Civil War when that hits
theaters but my next big Marvel movie
video will probably be next Sunday
there's gonna be a whole bunch of
Superbowl trailers but really I'm
excited about the Marvel stuff a whole
bunch of awesome stuff happening this
week while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for all
my Captain America Civil War videos and
you can click here for my Deadpool 2
girls 1 punch video I'll let you guys
find out about that if you haven't seen
it yet there's a lot of fun thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you